that's pretty good this is B that's all it says
right only line that's this is hiccup citizens of
the reject Nation it's me Tera Erikson alongside
Gregory Alba God he doesn't join in on the rap
game you guys heard the rap in my voice he was
supposed to continue it it in the voice with all
this noise o that's good we're going to watch
How to Train dragon three three with Terra and
Gregory yeah man flying through the sky feeling
so free oh my hair wow what do I see the Night
Fury so good don't forget to leave a like for
that what you got to type in the comments and
say how cool we are and don't forget to ring
the bell ring the bell also the real reject
has their own apparel line are you going to
tell them about it Gregory let me tell them
about it Terry okay look at here's one design
here's another design here's another design
I'm wearing one of the designs it's a soda got
another Design coming up right now I brought
my sister on board to become the head artist
for us and we've already sold a lot and it is
one of the absolute best ways to support the
channel to show your love as a citizen of the
reject still stuck in the fact that I haven't
been gifted any real rejects apparel go ahead
and leave it in the comments you can tell them
2023 you ear tshirt you earn your keep I need
a t-shirt then I would show up wearing the
apparel shout out the patreon don't forget
we call you super sexy super sexy when you join
on patreon.com you get to sync up with your full
copy watch with me and GRE are you ready cuz
I feel like I'm ready I'm ready man today my
emotions are stoic they're watch wild mine are
wild yours are stoic which is down here mine
is Hey where's my this is
Bine oh who are these jerks
meanies ha yeah oh yeah this is hiccup what are
you oh hell yeah oh yep oh he looks
taller he can handle some Flames ooh cool you're
a demon I'm not a demon see just a guy he's so
much older you walked through fire dragon scales
your human legs are last in thinkig that that's
a good entrance oh my goodness behold along with
his sister who insisted on coming that's my intro
oh she looks older to me find a sitter demons
everywhere it's the end of the world ouchie we're
going to get you out of here oh my God they're
like Dragon rights activists now get the rescues
out of here get that night uh-oh step aside
let me handle the tough guy stuff it's a cool
warer that's two for
me look out sorry wow it's
still one shot yeah it's
awesome good hustle
boys toothless time to go what do
you sense my boy what is it I saw
that on on the cover yeah but
I didn't want to ruin that for
you you always have my back butt they have to
go back for the Night Fury baby my cat's ta and
copper are a black cat and a white cat but they're
not lovers I'm assuming they're lovers in this one
well felt feminine this is Burke this is Burke
home away from home so many dragons now dream
so settle in and light your worries melt away
the cuisine's fiery do people actually get a like
visit here now I guess we my friend have dragons
lots and lots of dragons are you sure it's not oh
that's cool overpopulated I mean it looks like
it like it's busting at the seams hiccup's mom
any notes on my bone crushing assault or was
it pretty much much perfect still doesn't know
her name it was Indescribable and please call me
Valk it has been a year first name bis it's only
been a year that was pretty sloppy perhaps you
all rely a little bit too much on your dragons
and not enough on one another then what's
the point of having dragons you found a new
friend oh no oh no uh-oh yeah I'm surprised
B is still standing there's like right when
we came in with one shot there's a building fing
down CU there was too many on there and now here
we go oh boy yeah you guys are going to have to
find a new home maybe the one that mom had before
hang up those Saddles and get married are they
still not like I guess not with you wearing the
pants there's still hope wow not awkward at all
a don't be like that I thought they were already
buried down two more Trapper barges spotted
in the straight so we go after them one day
you're going to pick a fight you can't win oh
yes oh that's that's some foreshadow I wonder
who the villain will be this time uhoh whoa this
looks like the dead marshes out of the two towers
yeah oh oh last time the villain was really
large and this one's like gaunt yeah is this
my dear warlord how go your plans to
conquer the world that's definitely a
villain stoic boy he in his peace loving
Dragon Riders continue to raid our ships
and steal our dragons but I'm in the business
of killing dragons dragon slayer why bother me
because the flock is protected by a night
Fury a crap oh now it so we'll pay you to
capture him and bring the flock to us
we even have your favorite bait oh no a
female is that a a white Fury yeah it looks just
like cuz that's why I was like why are they oh
it must be a like is it because it's white is it
going to did he just kill is this the first time
we've seen a human actually kill a dragon young
Chief will bring me the Night Fury they don't
have a leader just a boy okay I was going to say
is because it's white are they going to call day
Fury and then he killed that Dragon just straight
up and I it's my job as Chief to protect us zup
and one day when you're all growing up that job
will be passed on to you oh this is going to be
a full circle Beyond beond the sunset lies the
home of the Dragons ships that sailed too close
to it only to drop off the edge of the world
that's where we got to go to Tales of a great
waterfall and Dragons guarding the entrance to
a hidden world it's going to look beautiful one
day I'll find the hidden world and seal it up
so that people and Dragons will fight no more
no do you know what's going to happen they're
going to have to send the Dragon right oh God
no somebody's going to seal it up no I don't
know what's going to happen yeah have they'll
have to cuz it's overcrowded or to keep them
safe yeah they need a Haven or they could be
like here's the area where you could go visit
over the waterfall and you come visit Burke
anytime getting pretty good at gliding on your own
bud no no oh my God I hate it I mean good for you
toothless that's so sad but necessary a secret
land at the edge of the world where dragons live
totally Out Of Reach be the answer to all of our
problems by moving the dragons there all of us oh
and abandon our home of Seven Generations yeah you
need enough room the home your father left you to
protect I mean it's just a rock the reality honey
is that houses are falling down left and right
oh
toothless he's going to go fly oh no don't
get lost or hurt please he's off on his
own is that the white day Fury the
white the white day Fury oh no is it
a trap I mean more than likely right
yeah I just don't like it but it's
so glistening looks like a Listerine
commercial she's so sparkly she has
glitter so [Music] cute all right let's
see how dragons Court each other oh she's
so scared should be scared but
a man just comes up to you like
that oh my God love the reflections in their eyes
no no what's that what was that sound oh my go H
hiccup oh yeah no no need to kill
us no don't go back to the mean
people a poor guy who what does she just like
Snap flash into another dimension I love a lot
of these tracking shots bright a light Fury yeah
your is better probably yeah could have gone there
we didn't get there night yeah no well a night
what's gotten into you what is all this slobbering
and panting you know exactly what's going on
toothless has a girlfriend but it's so sweet look
oh my God it's the cutest thing I love all right
let's head back to the woods and see if we can
find her too much practice on your arm it'll be
hard but you have my word and until I break that
word I won't it must be like a really long game
of baiting over there what is that in the time
here you see some shiny thing in the woods tried
to attack and then it got got away it got away
nope it's a trap it's going to happen again
huh it's definitely TR no don't move a muscle
hey wow oh he's smart that was smart yeah
I know this handiwork grimmel the grizzly
the smartest Dragon Hunter I ever met next to
me of course sure Mar my words he'll be back
they we be waiting for him you should listen
to that guy you're being too confident Man
Too confident take a page out of Terror
and Greg lack of confidence goes a long
way is he there I assume this
has to be yeah Grimsley right
yeah there he is this is quite good oh that is
impressive toothless no your father knew
of me now there was a chief making it his
mission to destroy the beasts so that you
could grow up in a better world he changed
his mind look where that got him cold man
that's cold I am the Night Fury killer I've
hunted every last one but yours you are
going to give me that dragon or I will I
will never give him up we know it oh he's
not there oh hiccup you one up did we get
him now oh cool you think you can come into
my home and threaten my dragon this is Burke
and we have defended our way of life from far
worse than you or was this part of his plan
I'm afraid you're mistaken youve never
seen anything like me oh what please no
God as look out oh it's like a scorpion
dragon is that
acid it looks like spooky G uh ooh that
is horrifying have my dragon ready when I
return or I will destroy everything you love
hey the dragons are already destroying Burke
for you buddy yeah you guys got to make it
to the end of the waterfall and do it quick
we're Vikings we don't run from a fight he's
a predator single-minded and patient he won't
stop until he gets what he wants I'm with Eris
we have to take this threat seriously jealous
I don't see a way of staying here any longer
right you got to get out if we want to live
in peace with our dragons we need a better plan
I'm saying we have to disappear take the dragons
to a place where no one will find them this
is a crazy proposal my father he made notes
and maps in search of the ancestral home of
all dragons I know this is our home my father
left me to protect it home is the people I say
Burke is wherever we go I'm with him who else
yes okay oh all right just transition to
okay the Night Fury escaped you again I
encouraged it they've abandoned their
only defensible position yeah exactly
the Night Fury is distracted I introduced
him to your female the light Fury scent
he won't be able to leave it okay she's
following us this is all part of this plan
whoa hold up tothless oh I hate the fact that
they're just being just totally used look who
it is no no no fin [Music] okay he's getting in
the way of us oh my God he's conflicted my God
he really is so great not a word [Music] Furies
can't survive in the cold so they haven't gone
North they're trying to put distance between
themselves and enemies to the east and south
oh my God this guy is a tactician gang I
I said make Camp not build a new Village
died and made you Chief what dude all right
you could stay until Toothless and I find the
hidden world I should head back to make sure
we weren't followed I'll go with you you're
far too important here yeah this plan though
I wish it were possible I fear it can't last
hiccup I mean you know I tried to do the same
for years yeah very realistic Toth no it's too
early light fury it's stalking around with her
scent whoa what camouflage oh my gosh that's
cool
oh my
God I do love the visual storytelling of
just them like how it's you can't have
dialogue with it you know you just got to
watch the body language of them falling in
love are you good oh
no
no hey hey she did it she's so much more
confident than [Music] him that's so
cute he's literally being a wingman for
come on hiccup woo [Music]
her oh my God maybe just be
herself
oh my [Music]
God he's losing it just you're
trying too hard man oh I love
it like a bat that's
[Applause] cool look [Music] sick of your
advice oh that's
her oh she's like pink damn
this environment is gorgeous
yeah a she hates him so much this poor guy
whenever he flies it's so sad
he needs to be able to fly with
her oh he's going to come with like a
permanent solution I bet I'm impressed
embracing change I am proud of you he's my
best bud I want him to be happy and besides
it's just until he brings her back he's
displaying dad qualities bring her home
my son down at the latest now save it
for your girlfriend go on get out of
here it's okay this is going to
have such a sad ending man you
just totally feel it want it I really don't want
it [Music] oh what a terrifying thing to ride solo
over [Music] uhoh
no yeah good job [Applause]
Dragon oh great shot wow that would
be so close in the theater as well
yeah was it a storm no it's the sound of
her when she's oh whatever that's called
there she is okay hey check me out so cute got
some [Music] upgrades now storytelling really
takes advantage of its animated medium oh my
god oh see that is a storm Gregory sorry you
were 100% right wow this is not romantic guys
what are you doing yeah like is something bad
gonna can he get it might have been that too I'm
just saying okay like he can't get hurt cuz he
has metal on him right like electrocuted with
its tail uh whatever he'll be fine they'll be
[Music] fine he just took a
[Music]
[Applause] shot oh W he locked his
potential every every movie he's
upgraded that's such a cute shot I can't stand
it oh my God he gave her the lick oh so [Music]
beautiful W waterfall yes is there
going to be more dragons over
there whoa great sound design good transition
too there wow what if the tail broke would you
relax he's probably having the time of his
life how would I know she never comes around
and when she does she's always rushing off
she's so wild and skittish I'm just going to
say it I don't trust her this is great grand
is tracking us he has 100 ships with enough
cages for all of our dragons we have to take
him out of the mix by going there to capture
him I'm with him who else it's not going
to work every time oh he creates it himself
okay oh remember stealth missions don't always
start off stealthy but she saw him so he's
lurring yeah he knows exactly what's going
to happen he's always one step ahead yep yep
okay that flame will draw a lot of attention to
you well he already knows they're there so just
doesn't really matter what is that okay wow
you just locked yourselves in first rule of
the hunt separate the prey from its pack
you've just removed yourselves from the
equation a this gloating bastard but I was
a boy and I Came Upon a Night Fury I killed
it where it slipped this is why he's the worst
this could have been the path hiccup went down
but you have dragons of your own pre like
drugged into obedience with their own Venom
oh drugged not even you precious Alpha could
control them oh that is so Sinister allow me
to demonstrate take [Applause] cover oh
split up w who it melts oh wow okay but
it's gak and then it's fire it is like some
type of acid fire some fiery gak I don't even
know I wonder if light and night if they
put their power together they can override
[Applause] it well also if they could
just take those serums out of their
foreheads they might but they've been
injected with it right he's constantly
injecting his dragons with their own serum
to make them amenable and I'm like well
if he if they could pull those out then
the dragons wouldn't be right jumper all
right oh yes good job awesome he takes that
stupid baby everywhere what is she doing what
just happened uh where is ruffnut we we left her
behind how could you not notice she was missing
you ride a two-headed dragon I feel like how
ruffnut is every day dumb we will get ruffnut
back don't worry if they're stuck with rough nut
I'm more worried about them I know what you're
thinking you've never had a prisoner this hot all
the boys love me except Aon who totally lost his
chance that ship has sailed boy sorry and hicup
is practically married to that roundhead astd
don't give information can't we just feed her to
your dragons hey what do you have to eat around
here I'm allergic to fish you should know that
that's all they have at that stupid new island
oh yeah here we go we know it is B to come out
most annoying creature ever to cross my path a
I got to let her go and then follow her stress
is not good for you that's really annoying long
losers it's like just it's a little too stupid
for me yeah where where is she heading she's
tracking something aren you girl there's nothing
but miles and miles of what oh is it the waterfall
okay whoa oh wow I didn't realize it
was shaped like that yeah that's not
that's like a whole different thing
oh wow oh no this is beautiful where
would the humans stay w it's even more
Avatar did Avatar rip this wao wow oh my
gosh oh how gorgeous who baby dragons are these
all baby dragons maybe and they're lighting up
like there's like energy connection between
them oh how gorgeous oh this would have been
so cool to seen the theaters w oh what
what oh my goodness I mean it can't be
that far from where their Camp to now so
they can visit whoa oh my goodness it is
a whole world amazing and that's the world
that they need because how look how huge it
is yeah of things it's crystals L mushrooms
are they playing you'll spook them are they
like king and queen of it like well they're like
bouncing off of this like Crystal's energy or
what oh wow he's even still the alpha to all
of them I mean night furies
seem to be the most dominant
ones now that's a King serving his Queen
oh a they are so cute together I love them so
much is like Dragon culture so pretty we going
to have to let toothless go buddy it's so sad
but I'm just glad he's like happy at least we
should go screw that teror oh no I know but
like oh no no no is it the Bad Dragon is it
the same Bad Dragon I I mean it has to be right
or is just one of the a lives there that feels
threatened scal this is crazy go whoa whoa whoa
oh is it cuz like still in this in this world like
I'm sorry but I humans are bad right like they
haven't been are you going to get us a new mom
I don't want another your mom was the only woman
for me she was the love of my life but with love
comes loss son it's part of the deal there's no
greater gift than love it's a real doozy this is
why whenever I get a pet like it's going to hurt
you I have to say body one day it's okay but you
belong there with her what already we'll find a
way to man is she there she follow a a she loves
him
you might not have to say goodbye after all but
is that still the right choice no they're going
to have to go back to the world eventually
how did you escape I annoyed them till they
let me go wait wait Grim will let you go so
dumb oh you're catching on now get ready for
battle K become the most hated character this
whole trilogy toothless no I don't it gives me
anxiety no oh my God I hate
it no no no
no dang
it no you got to be kidding me
this is so [Music] cruel [Applause]
oh he's saying stay back because he doesn't
want her to die oh don't feel too badly you
tried your best this guy is such an [__]
Nothing Without Your Dragon that's not
true oh they're all going I feel like the
same screw-up I was before I met toothless
but I was the first to believe in you you
were the bravest knucklehead I know you
are romantic toothless didn't give you
that hiccup he just made it easier and
now it's going to be a lot harder what are
you going to do about it probably something
stupid wow it's coming full circle every good
Trilogy calls back to the first one how are we
going to get our dragons back without dragons
trust me okay how though can you explain are
we going to take a ship are we going to build
a ship are they're all going to get suits oh
yeah maybe jump off the cliff you try to keep up
all right wa that would be so scary oh the wing
suit should have dragon scale on it yes I would
love to see him knocked out multiple times oh
okay yeah yeah yes strategize eyes
I love how toothless has also really
become a leader as well like they really
grew together that's so beautiful oh what
a cool shot yeah what are you waiting for get in
there no no no no no yeah you blow him
up toothless good job no no no uh-oh oh
no oh oh what no at least landed
there let's just see somebody kill him already
I hate him oh yeah take this serum
out of there oh God no no no no no
no yes over two coming through surprise
sorry about that come on oh working as a
team sorry we're late for the
party you're right on time what
are you going to do it's fun that they they
brought fire wow this is some epic action
wow another they a cage that's great
they brought the fire to Burke and now
Burke brought the fire to them where
is he leading him this is bugging me
oh because Night Fury can't
survive in the cold yeah oh
no what damn we all come on take the serum
out of is this a do the thing do the thing
yeah what are you doing can he handle it
oh he's got the dragon scale he can handle
it no it boom did he just kill his
other dragons uh yeah did hiccup
survive waa no oh no oh oh God such oh my God
oh my God fighting over a dragon that's your
plan she'll go get him take the thing off go get
him save him Let Go like Let Him let go [Music]
yeah oh he has his suit uh okay uh please
don't let this be a thing where he saves his
child but he dies ah no I can't handle
it what no no no no no no [Music] no a
sa oh she she's come around cuz I was going lose
it I knew you'd come around that's exactly what I
said I really thought toothless
might come in man what a like
roller Co through the last like
15 minutes has jeez [Applause]
a this movies try not to cry challenges Jesus
Christ's hey good morning bud here you
go he's all
yours you on your best
behavior in front of [Music]
people oh does he want to
go to the world he misses
it
you're right bud it's time oh
I was so busy fighting for a
world that I wanted I didn't think about what you
needed you've looked after us for
long enough time to look after
yourselves
all you got to say about all the
dragons oh Stormfly my good
girl so long you big ugly beast I miss
you oh Cloud Jumper oh man that must be
the hardest for her go on butt lead them
to the Hidden World you'll be safe
there our world doesn't deserve you
yet go How to Train Your Dragon for make it
happen this is so sad hey she's back for
CIA
like the first one like was
a father son story and this
is like a father son story that's really
well done Trilogy man that's really well
done oh man this this going to be a hiccup
like 45 or something this going to be like
super old really old at Christmas time
I'm I'm done crying this guy ages so
fast oh they're getting married
oh
Arn W this looks just like my
wedding for the chief and chief Das come cry
to my full thick beard oh my God we we have
tissues here for tera's ears let's explain after
what I mean by that I never have tissues your
fire this
for I pad out there were dragons when I was a
boy oh there were great Grim Sky dragons
oh my God oh my God little brown Scuttle
dragons had hunted down the mice and rats
and well organized packs two sea dragons some
say they crawled back into the sea others say
they were nothing but folktales to begin with
a look at that that was
[Music] great
hey hey there bud remember you sniff it it's okay
yeah hey I am glad to see you
too he's not going to eat your
father oh my
God that's it
a eat them toothless then smash
the black oh my God it's so cute
wow you're going to make your kid throw up oh
asard oh my gosh it's so cute I thought
asra would be riding her oh IIT know she
got her Dragon back yeah Legend says that
when the ground Quicks or lava spews from
the earth it's the dragons letting us know
they're still here or Earth deteriorating
and we'll guard the secret until the time
comes when dragons can return in peace
nice yay wow they should do How to Train Your
Dragon in 2025 put it in modern day movie it's
so good I can't even stand how good it is
that's a really like well structured Trilogy
it perfectly wraps up the story of a Trilogy and
it it complement and mirrors and revisits really
well done oh man when he goes with his family and
he sees them oh man I can't be doing that that's
too cute the the very beginning of the movie is
telling you right at front hey they going to go
sear like at the very beginning and I was like
oh no and I was just trying to prepare myself for
it and and and I felt my my soul like go like you
know when sometimes in real life if I have to say
bye to someone I'm like you shut down down I found
myself shutting down and I got to be I'm like no
you got to let's learn from this movie learn to
say goodbye it's you learn to let go man it's the
last one connect with it by the way uh our reviews
go up on like apple and Spotify and stuff so if
you're listening there please uh leave a like or
no not leave a like rate it you know do that thing
helps us out there helps us out help us out that's
our our introduction we just throw you into the
muck of it no introduction on the reviews there
we just watched out of trainer Dragon 3 there's
our introduction uh okay yeah we have tissues here
I'm never yeah I'm still oh you guys just saw if
you're watching the video I just took the tissues
out of my ear because Greg puts the volume up to
like 2550 million DB and it hurts my ear so I put
tissues in there to even it out a little bit for
me I'm a weird viewer if I'm watching a comedy I
don't like sub subtitles but if I don't if it's
not a cuz I'm like it's going to ruin the joke if
I'm watching a comedy right but if it's a drama if
it's drama or whatever other genre you'll have
it I I I have subtitles because my mind's like
I don't know what they're saying like I just I
can't register so I usually prefer with subtitles
um and then when we're re doing these reactions
uh you know sometimes people think we miss [__]
when we're talking I'm like no we actually don't
because the volume's so loud right and I I like
to be absorbed into the movie the movie yeah I
I love that experience but it really when he's
absorbed it's I'm literally like unfortunately I
can't control tera's Vol like we share the same
volume level so to compensate I left out a box of
tissues for her her and she puts tissues in her
ears and it is not one of those things where we
were like prepare to cry grab no it's just it's
only if I'm here he leaves the tissues out so I
can put him in my ear and luckily well there we
go this movie three was not as torturous for me
thank you so much like two I went through a lot
more torture and obviously I told you it was a
like a perfect movie this one I love and adore
like each one to me is I'm like this is a perfect
Trilogy like what it's so freaking good but this
one I was not as tormented as much I still was a a
little bit but not not as much which thank you for
that yeah people prepared us saying most people
said it wasn't as good and and I will I will meet
you I will meet people there uh I appreciated that
because uh have you seen the Kung Fu Panda movies
no yes uh maybe I don't know I have I did ride
the ride when it existed at Universal Studios
which is not a ride it's like a theater so I feel
like maybe I don't know I'm not a big fan of that
I don't know uh so people said the same thing
about that which is DreamWorks cuz like one's
great two's amazing and then three is a dip it's
still good okay and so I was kind of expecting
sort of a situation like that based off of what I
saw a couple of common say yeah and I started to
feel that in in the first half of this movie like
okay this is this the first two transcended um you
know kids animation movie like it just they just
especially the second one was just like this is
a cinematic experience you know and I'm not even
aware I'm watching an animated movie targeted for
children uh you know and this one felt more like
that uh uh significantly more like it felt a lot
more the acte structure kind of or like do you
mean execution the dialogue the back and forth
a lot of it felt like oh I was more aware I'm
watching like a kid's anime animated movie this
time but I mean it's not that's not too it's like
it's only a put down in comparison to the first
two as a standalone film that that doesn't work as
a standalone like you need the other two to watch
this but just an isolation like no it's still
above average of your of your typical animated
kids movie and in the last like 20 30 minutes
of this I'm like okay this is the How to Train
Your Dragon movie that um from the other that that
matches the par of the other two you know I agree
yeah oh my God when he especially when he I mean
the the part with the villain in this one is a
little bit shorter of like he's around but you're
right we cut back to like uh you know um night uh
Toothless and the girl like flying around in their
relationship but I was constantly in my stomach
going like wait isn't he using the light Fury to
get to them like I thought something was going to
continually happen while they were falling for
each other and it didn't until way later than I
thought I mean he was but he was it wasn't like
mind controlling her yeah that's what I thought
too like is he look she on it in some way without
knowing you know right and like she wasn't so cool
but it it made it less the the villain esque part
less like palpable I guess yeah um so that it is
more I guess kid-friendly when we do cut back
to him he's there he's making up a plan we it's
kind of an underlying thing where we like we know
he's going to pop up but it wasn't as intense as
two where I was like I I think I screamed like
murder that guy a million times and I didn't I
didn't have that yes I wanted the villain to die
but it was not as strong as in the last one yeah
I think the I would say like the skeleton and the
bones of this one is really really good it's the
it's the overall execution like pacing wise uh
tonal wise and and like and like even with the
villain too like it it there's stuff that's like
it's goofy you know stuff that's a little bit more
goofy still good though I'm not just saying that's
be nice it's still good still above average I love
the scenes with with light Fury and when they're
glowing yeah when when they're bonding and with
night and light Fury yeah and uh when they're when
they're just you know falling in love with each
other like that to me was oh this is true animated
movie right here where there's no dialogue we have
to just connect with their expressions and their
body language and their eyes and I I love how they
take advantage of that with them and for a movie
about dragons and not and dragons that can't talk
or at least speak our our our language it was so
cool to just get that experience and we didn't
get that till the third movie and I thought that
was great to provide that for us yeah and the the
themes too of um love and letting go and just
the I'm really impressed with how they brought
it back with the cuz you know it it never felt
like a fatherson story to me between Toothless
and Hiccup um right until until here where it's
like really defined because he always says like
you're my best friend yeah and and so I think
even making Toothless in the likeness of a cat
even makes it more like that you know um the time
of filming this I'm not been public about it at
all I've had some crazy cat experiences with my my
babies started right I'm working off an hour and
40 minutes of sleep right now I was at the ER this
morning with my cat um and then there was a whole
Fiasco of things over the last few days and I'm
but but they're okay none of them are dead they're
okay there was a situation A few days ago where
it was it was looking really terrifying um so but
but like I've been telling the people who I have
told to who like don't have cats like look I don't
have children so I'm not going to be one of those
guys who says they're they're my children I'll say
they're I say they're my children they're the but
I'm talking to someone with kids I'm like they're
the closest thing I have have to a child you know
and and at the end of the day they're still family
to me and so it's been a really hard few days
so this especially right now really hit home and
and I think to draw the paral because you know
you'll see that with like man's best friend is
dog and then here you don't really say that with
your cats uh right and but uh here or at least
the expression is not as prominent and this to
bring it to a fatherson story between Hiccup and
Toothless and then for hiccup to be learning the
lessons from stoic and like the flashbacks were
appropriately done uh yeah no I I still overall I
was like oh I like this one and then by the end I
was like no I would say I loved it yeah you know
oh yeah I mean him him learning to like I guess
yeah like really his lesson in learning to let go
Al those he hiccup has had to let go of a lot of
things you know his dad prior to this but him
like on another level of um just having it be
his decision and seeing like toothless grow up and
he has to go off on his own um yeah it it was nice
and it was nice to see him make the the tale for
him of like well you know he's he's my buddy and
I want to do what's best for him um uh so that he
could go fly and with his girlfriend and stuff and
uh [Laughter] I I feel like um towards the end of
him and the relationship with astred I'm like it
could have really only not only gotten there but
was really only going to get there I think until
there was more space to allow their relationship
because before it was like a lot of just um Hiccup
and Toothless right and asterids on the outskirts
and they have dragons and they go and they fight
them and they fly around and now their life is
more like like well we have to live kind of like
like humans do right for a while and that allowed
him to like really form their relationship cuz
everyone was like get married get married and she
was like we don't really need to do that it's not
like she was ever pressuring him but the space
I think and allowed the opportunity for them to
start a family and this space allowed uh tooth was
the same I mean he needed space in his own world
the Dragons Were ripping their world down they
weren't going to punish them for it cuz they're
good people and yeah I think like him saying
the world of humans and Dragons is not ready
to coexist yet he did say that in this movie so
it's like they tied it up in a nice little pretty
bow um and I think the yet we did see towards the
very end of that he does get to go visit them but
I thought like oh wow are they going to do like
a fourth where there is eventually like maybe a
little bit of a world because it's so huge in
there where they can't all live together again
I don't know I doubt it um because they tied it
up nicely where the dragons get their world they
get theirs they can go visit say hi to the family
and go back home they should do it like in the far
future like yeah like a long time from now yeah
we're dead and then the movie comes out yeah no
I'm saying the movie should take place in the
future oh got it oh yeah well I mean going off
what you're talking about because a big part of
in addition to him letting go this is hiccup's
Journey of discovering his selfworth you know
like I I didn't even think about that of until
this movie really put a spotlight on it that there
is I mean the saying the word codependent it's
I feel like there such that's such a negative
connotation to that there is a dependency that
he had on on hi uh on toothless yeah and but
it wasn't like a toxic thing you know that's
that's the thing about saying codependency it's
such a toxic Association it it wasn't a toxicity
whatsoever however he did put all of his worth in
in that and he felt like to be a leader and to be
a warrior and to be a fighter and all it was very
much dependent on night fear on his yeah on his
Night Fury and and the dragons and everything and
like that's what gives them their power and that's
what makes them special and unique and and this
was about embracing the people but also taking
the lessons learned from them uh of of the bond of
the bonding and even with the the wing suit stuff
and everything like there he you see him form into
a you're watching him become a man over the course
of these films yeah up to the final frames of
this movie where he's he's a family man right
by the end of this uh this Trilogy which is great
like this really is his journey and it's the same
thing with toothless where he's growing up and
becoming a becomes a leader and a and and a and a
family dragon as well it's really cool it's it's a
really well done narrative like as a Trilogy it's
a really solid narrative for from all three and
you don't really see that with a lot of trilogies
and a lot of times the the the TR the third one
usually sucks or they don't they try to tie it
back to the first one in a way to to wrap it up
at it feels force or whatever and this one does
it really well where a lot of it kind of sneaks
up on you you know yeah I agree and like just to
touch on the selfworth thing they made like astred
sort of like the mom was at the head of IT of
going you you have to help him to see because the
second like uh that hiccup was gone she was like
on top of it which I liked um and I like that you
know asard had to remind him a couple of times um
to really so that he could really see for himself
that he didn't necessarily need hiccup in order to
lead which was nice yeah um I mean listen I I give
it an eight and a half I mean I I want to go nine
out of 10 I just the this whole trilogy overall 13
out of 10 yeah 23 out of 10 like I love it all I
agree with you as a as a Trilogy I would say Bravo
I would still rank this I mean emotionally this is
like number two for me emotion yeah um but as a
movie as a whole it's number two number three um
but I mean number two is is obviously number one
number two put you through the ringer number two
is was just some other Majestic thing yeah that
was and and I also thought last thing I'll say
is I think the the world exploration of the the
Hidden World we didn't spend too much time there
but I thought that was smart to kind of keep
it something that is more for Hiccup and and
uh they never gave her Fury we never gave her name
right I don't call her Linda um for Toothless and
Linda mhm for them to have great name something
felt just Fantastical and mystical and ethereal
and Lind something that is not fully tangible
for Humanity definitely Linda sure yeah Linda
like definitely yeah very ethereal um the world
not Linda I mean her too yeah got it I thought
he was talking about the name I mean I I describe
most women that way as an excuse to never have hit
on them oh got it yeah as as like oh yeah women
they're ethereal and and and not tangible for The
Human Experience and do you call them all lindas
I mean yeah some people say Karen but I think
that's a negative word and Lind Linda's not nope
no it's just just Linda yeah got it well we on the
same bit now we know I think we're on the same bit
yeah I mean I think we have been the for the last
minute and a half all right so I think I guess we
say goodbye now right can we shout someone out oh
yeah let's do it okay okay all right all right all
right I I got this okay we're gonna take it away
kid we're gonna do this a little bit different
oh different I wanted to experiment oh all right
get ready for it experiment we're going to do this
in real time I have opened up chat gbt everyone's
favorite thing what are we doing all right pick a
name out of these four Ricardo Martinez all right
Ricardo Martinez all right for Ricardo Martinez
give some uh okay let's give him some words and
let's play a little a slight Mad Libs game here
okay uh an item oh a lamp a lamp yep okay and
then um an an adjective oh okay he's um playful
playful okay uh give another item another item
yeah H spaghetti spaghetti that's an item I
was going to say fork and I I was like no the
spaghetti okay mood mood uh I I I was going to
say like he's dark but I kind of don't but he's
playful so like doesn't make sense so maybe let's
try it dark okay dark dark let's go dark let's go
uh all right uh give me a um um an occupation he's
a doctor doctor okay uh and then uh just anything
that comes to mind confetti confetti okay confetti
y all right I have a YouTube channel where I need
to shout out my Patron Ricardo Martinez create a
shout out for me with these items 40 words making
it special and make sure to include the words
Greg is a really good typer I would do that and
make a lot of mistakes I did spell include wrong
yeah but they get it all right Ricardo Martinez
let's see how creative this AI really is oh boy
here we go we could have done better we're gonna
have to sit here all right read it loud and proud
big shout out to our incredible Patron Ricardo
Martinez like a lamp in the dark you light up our
Channel you playful support is the spaghetti to
our sauce that's not bad doctor of dedication
here's some virtual confetti for you oh and
through the confetti side wow it was it's the Hat
with the stuff coming out oh my god wow oh yeah
that was well done good job chat is taking over
that's I guess that's better than anything me and
Gregor could have done I was hiring writers for
months to shout out these patrons just not with
me because I'm a great improviser you know I'm
off the cuff here you are off the cuff but all
the other shout outs Wild Ride hired Riders when
all I needed to do was type this into chat gbt
there's 30 riders in the closet right now scream
sobbing because they just lost their job pitch me
a plot for How to Train Your Dragon 4 that takes
place in TW 2070 50 oo nice when we are both dead
title how to change drag echo of Tomorrow a
postapocalyptic world where dragons have been
forgotten and humanity is spread out across small
isolated colonies harnessing technology to surv oh
my God it's going way too long that's too creative
stop gener it's it's too creative there's a stop
J anybody oh my God thank God my God busting heart
of NE city state God I have a producer mentality I
don't want to read that much no stupid new lines
of a plot summary stupid did not give you money
get out God Chad I I almost I almost I was almost
on their board I got to hire a rider he almost
lost it I guess I'll pay them fairly you guys can
come out of the closet now he hired you back take
them shackles off you've had the key the whole
time time they're saying they don't want to come
out cuz see the trust is ruined you know weird
it's ruined what did we just do here the trust
is ruined they were 30 riders in the closet and
you were like I mean trust how do I solve this
writer I thought was going to
type in how do I get rid of terara
ericon that would have been good draging out yeah
[Music] bye